well some breaking news now driving from  two Suites just to tweets just sent by  President Trump this is what he's  written I have authorized the federal  government to arrest anyone who  vandalizes or destroys any monument  statue or other such federal property in  the US with up to 10 years in prison per  the Veterans Memorial Preservation Act  or such other laws that may be pertinent  this action is taken effective  immediately but may also be used retro  actively for destruction or vandalism  already caused there will be no  exceptions  this comes after police in Washington DC  use pepper spray to stop protesters  trying to remove a statue close to the  White House of former President Andrew  Jackson a former Army General and slave  owner responsible for signing the Indian  Removal Act which led to thousands of  Native Americans being removed from  their land